[Music]
turns out Prince Harry will be allowed
to wear his military uniform to Queen
Elizabeth's funeral a source close to
the royal family tells E.T quote it was
a decision made without Prince Harry
requesting a change and that decision
for his grandma's vigil taking place at
Westminster Hall comes as a surprise
since that wasn't always the case we're
told that while Harry is still unable to
wear his military uniform to any event
his uncle prince Andrew is allowed to be
in uniform for the final vigil only
another potential change for Prince
Harry and his family his two kids Archie
and lillibet may receive Royal titles
along with Meghan Markle and Prince
Harry getting theirs back we're told by
the palace the issue of titles is going
to be something that is going to be
sorted out after the official morning
period and don't forget the Royals have
a further seven full days of mourning
after the funeral on Monday so what of
the titles for Archie and lilybeck which
has caused I think it's fair to say a
storm of controversy well by law now
that Charles is king any sons of The
Sovereign are entitled to take the
prince title the hrh title and their
children are entitled to take the hrh
title it is why Prince Andrew's
daughters Beatrice and Eugenie are their
Royal highnesses Princess Beatrice of
York and Princess Eugenie of York now
eagle-eyed Royal Watchers will have
noted that on the official Royal website
Archie and Lily Bert are not prince and
princess Archie Lily but yet they are
still Mr and Miss Archie and lillibet I
think the reason that they are Master
Archie and Miss Lily but still is
because a formal decision hasn't been
taken yet as to the announcement of
those titles are there going to be hrh
it's unlikely given that that is what
Harry and Megan have dropped but I
believe that it's the case that they
will be prince and princess and I think
a lot rides on these titles are we going
to see this eagerly anticipated
autobiography of Harry's are there going
to be more interviews essentially
trashing the royal family I think titles
are given to those who have earned them
and I think at the moment the jury might
still be out is there any chance that
Harry and Megan might be given their hrh
titles back well of course after makes
it after they made the announcement that
they were standing down as senior
members of the royal family that they
were no longer representing the then
Queen they were stripped of those
honorary titles now the queen made it
very clear that the door was always left
open for Megan and Harry to return if
they wanted to and I believe that it is
actually King Charles's hope that they
might well be able to come back into the
Royal fold in some sort of a capacity it
wouldn't be impossible to give back
those hrh titles but it would take an
absolute 360 turn on Megan and Harry's
part to give up all of the commercial
work and to come back as fully fledged
members of The Firm and I think there's
probably too much water under the bridge
for that to happen
[Music]